While more than a million Game of Thrones
fans found no issue crying out for HBO to
remake the eighth and final season with a
different group of writers, actress Sophie
Turner feels their protests to be incredibly
rude. And of course, if you didn't realize
by now: major spoilers ahead concerning the
series finale of Game of Thrones!
Turner, who portrayed Sansa Stark on the series
from its premiere episode in 2011 to its series
finale in 2019, addressed the recent fan petition
that's been making headlines in an interview
with The New York Times.
Created by a Change.org user known only as
"Dylan D," the appeal slams Game of Thrones
series creators, showrunners, and frequent
directors David Benioff and D.B. Weiss.
The petition accuses Benioff and Weiss of
being:
"[...] woefully incompetent writers when they
have no source material (i.e. the books) to
fall back on."
"He--"
He, what? What does he say about me?"
It also demands that HBO hire a team of, quote,
"competent writers" to create "a final season
that makes sense."
When asked for her thoughts about the uproar
from fans which reached an apex when the newly
minted Mad Queen Daenerys Targaryen set King's
Landing ablaze in the series' second-to-last
episode Turner responded:
"[...] I think [the petition] is disrespectful
to the crew, and the writers, and the filmmakers
who have worked tirelessly over 10 years [...] So
many people worked so, so hard on it, and
for people to just rubbish it because it's
not what they want to see is just disrespectful."
As Turner notes, Game of Thrones has been
subverting expectations since the very beginning,
so why should it change course during the
final season? The actress told The New York
Times:
"The thing about Game of Thrones that's always
been amazing is the fact that there's always
been crazy twists and turns, right from [season
one] with Ned's beheading. So Daenerys becoming
something of the Mad Queen — it shouldn't
be such a negative thing for fans. It's a
shock for sure, but I think it's just because
it hasn't gone their way."
Turner is far from the first Game of Thrones
star to speak out about audience backlash.
Kit Harington, who portrayed her onscreen
brother-slash-cousin Jon Snow, told Esquire
in April that any critic who makes a "negative
judgement" on the final season can, quote,
"go f--- themselves," as he feels they don't
fully understand how difficult it is to make
even one episode of Game of Thrones. Harington
told the publication:
"I know how much people cared about this.
I know how much pressure people put on themselves
and I know how many sleepless nights working
or otherwise people had on this show [...] Because
they cared about not letting people down.
Now if people feel let down by it, I don't
give a f---. That's how I feel."
The woman whose character's downfall catalyzed
the demand for a season 8 remake, Daenerys
Targaryen actress Emilia Clarke, also recently
opened up about the fan petition. Speaking
with The New Yorker, Clarke revealed that
the Mother of Dragons falling from grace to
become the Mad Queen and then facing the ultimate
betrayal when Jon Snow murders her, quote,
"seemed like the only way it could end" for
Dany. Clarke told The New Yorker:
"It absolutely breaks my heart that anyone
would think anything bad of her. But I'm sure
they will, and I can't control that. I don't
know that there was any other way."
On the other hand, Turner's character completed
her arc in an almost universally loved way.
After members of the remaining Great Houses
of Westeros met with one another and agreed
with Tyrion Lannister's suggestion that Bran
Stark should be crowned as the new king, Sansa
declared that the North would separate itself
from the other kingdoms, stand independent,
and never vote on who will become the protector
of the Realm. Everyone supported Sansa, and
when she returned home to Winterfell, she
was crowned the Queen in the North.
Turner said of Sansa's ending:
"I loved it. It's the only place that she
really, truly feels safe. The place that she's
the most capable of ruling. She would be a
fair and loving ruler, and it's what she's
been striving for this whole series: to go
back home, to protect her home [...]"
"I want you to help me, but I'll do it myself
if I have to."
Though she's frustrated by the way audiences
have reacted to the final season of Game of
Thrones, Turner isn't letting the negativity
stain her good memories of the series and
what it was like to be a part of it. The actress
told The New York Times:
"One of the things that I'll remember the
most is just the camaraderie and the family
that we all created from being on the show.
I've never felt such a strong bond with a
group of people in my life; I know that they're
going to be my family forever [...] I think
that's what I'll take away the most."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon. Subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one.